relativ tief
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge der
minecraft top 5 serie wo ich euch in
irgendeinem genre kategorie et cetera
irgendwas vorstelle wo ich denke ja oder
hab ich bin favoriten die ich euch auf
jeden fall mal zeigen möchte heute sind
das die minecraft shader wenn jetzt
denkt ach du hast doch schon top 5
shader gemacht
das war nur die top 5 creepy shader wo
sich dann die welt gedreht hat oder
irgendwie was anderes passiert ist das
hier sind jetzt aber wirklich meine top
5 lieblings shader mit denen ich auch so
nach freizeit spiele in irgendwelchen
projekten oder auch einfach so wenn ich
mal nicht aufnehme und deswegen würde
ich wie immer sagen das ist meine
meinung das heißt wenn ihr sagt dein
platz fünf ist aber meinen platz 1 dann
könnt ihr mir das gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
daran wird sich allerdings an meiner
meinung nichts ändern und das was ich
mir vorstelle ist halt nur meine meinung
und wir fangen direkt an mit platz
nummer fünf platz nummer fünf ist der
shader den ich hier gerade schon drin
haben uns war es dass der sill durchs
labyrinth shader ihr findet jeden
download link in der beschreibung zu
jedem shader und zwar ist das ein etwas
alternativer shader ihr seht stand er
arbeitet sehr mit der unschärfe wenn die
mails und auf das hühnchen achtet seht
ihr das ist sehr unscharf wenn ich dann
allerdings das hühnchen anvisiere es ist
sehr scharf und dann beispielsweise wenn
ich auch mal gegen einen baum gucke seht
ihr nur der baum hier ist der schlaf und
dann der rest wieder nicht oder hier
einfach da sieht man den unterschied
ganz gut das ist also eine unschärfe
filter deswegen ist der auch nur platz
fünf ich finde diese unschärfe mochte
ich zweimal aber finde ich jetzt nicht
mehr ganz so cool also der ist total
total anders als alle anderen shader mit
denen man normalerweise spielt also wir
haben hier so einen hohen kontrast wir
haben starken blaustich und halt einfach
diese unschärfe das ist schon sehr sehr
cool einerseits aber gerade deswegen ist
es halt auch noch einen platz vor
natürlich ist es cool dass wenn ich
gegen den baum cook oder so dass der
hintergrund unscharf ist das da wir ja
gar nichts gegen aber ich finde pvp so
was unnütz und auch bei irgendwelchen
anderen minecraft sachen auf servern
es ist zwar so ganz schöne damit kann
man mit sicherheit schöne cinematics
oder irgendwelche filme drehen aber
jetzt so für meinen gebrauch oder so ist
das ganze halt nicht so cool deswegen
machen wir auch schon direkt weiter mit
platz nummer vier
platz nummer vier ist dieser rudow place
shader und zwar erstmal dieser shader
hat zumindest in der version in der ich
sie spiele einige kleine bugs wie
beispielsweise hier das mit dem wasser
an sich ist es bei mir aber platz vier
weil das einfach so ein typischer
oldschool shader ist sowie aus der zeit
wo ich shader gerade kennengelernt habe
so alles so heller gemacht einfach
alles farbenreich konturen reicht das
wasser bewegt sich die blätter bewegen
sich beim wasser ist es halt so ihr seht
ja schon da sind teilweise so ein paar
dass man so durch das wasser durch
gucken kann es ist ein bisschen blöd
gerade deswegen und auch einfach weil
der shader hält wirklich genau so ist
wie man sich das quasi so damals
eigentlich gedacht hatte den shader
aussieht gerade deswegen ist es
platziert denkt ihr euch bestimmten wie
sieht denn jetzt so den shader
verständnis aus meint shader verständnis
jetzt ist so wie wir auch auf dem ersten
und zweiten platz zehn
so ein bisschen mehr mit der mit mit
nebel drehen und so ein bisschen dass es
bei nacht auch ein bisschen cooler wird
also dass ich meine wirklich cooler das
ist kühler wird ich meine wenn ich hier
beispielsweise mal times at night mache
bei diesen shader seht ihr schon da
verändert sich echt nicht viel ich weiß
gar nicht ob es so ist wenn ich eine
fackel in der hand nehmen ehe ist auch
nicht mal licht oder so natürlich eine
fackel macht hier liegt aber eine macht
also keine zusatzinfo keine
zusatzfunktionen irgendwie bei diesem
rudow place taylor deswegen ist es nur
mein platz vier und jetzt kommen auch
schon zu platz nummer drei platz nummer
drei ist der checker pig 13 v3 ultra
shader und smart zwar auch so ein paar
wasser bugs das seht ihr schon aber er
ist quasi auf der basis von diesem rudow
place shader nur ihr seht schon der hat
auch endlich man kühlen schatten der
rudow place shader da waren einfach nur
die sachen hier so aber der hier da seht
ihr schon da sind wirklich schatten
vorhanden auch von von tieren auch von
mir selber und so
deswegen ist das hier mein platz nummer
drei auch einfach es ist wirklich
einfach so man kann es so nennen es ist
rudow place mit ein bisschen mehr
features wie beispielsweise das wasser
ist ein bisschen wirklich so mit dem
schimmern und so wir haben natürlich
auch den bug der wohl auch übernommen
also ich möchte jetzt wirklich nicht
sagen dass es irgendwie von rudow place
einfach die datei genommen wurde
umgeschrieben wurde aber mich erinnert
dieser shader halt immer an den rudow
ball an denen ja doch an den rudow play
shader und das ist quasi einfach wie ich
sagen würde der role play shader genau
die gleiche farbtiefe gleichen
farbenreichtum haben reichtum hat sich
extrem komisch an ich bin der king der
faden ich habe meinen farbenreichtum
bleiben wir mal hier bei den shadern und
zwar wirklich einfach von den farben von
der farbtiefe von den konturen von der
sättigung von dem weißabgleich ist es
alles eigentlich genauso wie beim rudel
play shader nur dass ihr halt wirklich
noch genau dieser schatten dazu kommt
der sich auch das seht ihr der sich mit
der mit der sonne quasi mit verändert
der hacker zwei mal so ein bisschen
zurück aber das ist bei jedem shader
irgendwie der fall
und der gerade deswegen ist dieser
shader auch einen kleinen platz vor dem
rudow place shader allerdings erwarten
natürlich hier alle wieder platz zwei
und platz eins deswegen meine lieben
freunde machen wir direkt weiter mit
platz nummer zwei
platz nummer zwei ist der ceos
beziehungsweise sonic at the ultimate
shader sonic da was falsch dass ich bin
mir da nicht so sicher alle teenager
bestimmt stets für usher oder luca ist
es auf jeden fall der seo shader version
10.1 meine ich in der variante standard
also ich hab jetzt hier nicht ultra
genommen bei mir wird auch ultralauf ich
hab den downloadlink für ultra irgendwie
verfehlt dann habe ich mich außer den
standard 100 gewaltig den standard das
ist sehr sehr geil und zwar findet von
den farben noch viel geiler als die
beiden plätze der forschungs weshalb
wenig platz zwei und das wasser ist
endlich mal normal und das wasser finde
ich bei dem sie dabei dem bei dem von ex
trader sag ich jetzt einfach mal so ist
das wasser so unglaublich cool gelöst
ich meine es ist wirklich nicht mal in
meinem platz eins ist das wasser so
gelöst wie hier ich finde wirklich wenn
ich mal hier so auf die wasserhöhe ein
bisschen gehe wenn ihr euch das mal
anschaut das sieht so aus wie in der
karibik das ist richtig cool es einzig
blöde an diesem shader finde ich wenn
man in höhlen es hat man teilweise die
bucks das irgendwie einfach mal das
wasser das das licht nicht einleuchtet
und wenn ich jetzt mal beispielsweise
time of night setzte seht ihr schon
naja natürlich fackeln und so wenn ich
die hinsetzen die machen schon licht
aber wenn ich dieselbe einer hand nehme
ist das halt nur so ein bisschen licht
was gemacht wird und der ganze ton ist
sehr sehr düster also bei nacht wenn ich
das ganze nicht so cool und halt einfach
diese sache von wegen mit diesem
komischen lightning bugs wir sehen hier
auch irgendwie da vorne ist irgendwie
dann was angedacht das sind die schatten
einfach nur dass gerade schon das über
wasser jetzt auch schon irgendwelche in
welche fehler da irgendwie kommen aber
das war nur wegen dem schatten weil die
sonne relativ tief steht deswegen ist
der schatten noch relativ tief relativ
tief ich denke mal ihr wisst was ich
meine also der seo shader ist mein platz
nummer zwei nicht mein platz nummer eins
weil er doch einige bugs hat und vor
allem bei der nacht mich nicht so ganz
befriedigt sage ich mal
allerdings fragt ihr euch jetzt bestimmt
hey luca was
platz nummer eins da kommen wir jetzt
mal hin platz nummer eins wäre hätte es
anders vermutet ist der crusaders
version 5 ultra und zwar läuft dieser
shader bei mir extrem flüssig dafür was
er wirklich alles dazu hinzufügt wenn
ich 60 fps hätte würdet ihr sehen dass
ich hier mich um gucken kann und flüssig
wie sonst was aber ich habe halt nur 30
fps geringer ich bin übers wochenende
halt wieder von der uni beziehungsweise
so halb geschäftlich unterwegs deswegen
muss ich wieder ein wenig vor
produzieren und das 60 fps rennen dauert
halt einfach bei 30 fps dort bei mir
fünf minuten bei 60 fps bei mir
irgendwie 30 minuten
das kann ich einfach nicht machen weil
ich sehr sehr wenig zeit habe ein
bisschen zeitdruck frisches hemd an hier
ganz ganz ganz ganz schick hier der herr
mehr also der kula shaker ist die
zuschauer die auf minecraft leben
schauen wissen dass ich da auch immer
mit dem kula shaker spiel und einmal
sage das ist mein lieblingsspieler ist
obwohl alle im projekt nahezu mit dem
sonic se shader spielen ist dieser kula
shaker echt finde ich viel viel cooler
weil vor allem dieses cooler passt
einfach perfekt wenn ihr mal seht ich
schaue weiterhin und ihr seht wirklich
da hinten ist sonne nebelwand wenn ich
beispielsweise einfach in sonnen in
sonnenreichen bio mal gehe ich weiß zwar
nicht ob ich das irgendwie so als finde
also so ein winter bio oder auf
irgendwelchen bergen oder so dass sie
mega cool aus weil einfach in der in der
ferne sieht man quasi immer diesem nebel
kann ich den jetzt von ihr auch
irgendwie sehen
da sieht man dann quasi diesen nebel
oder hier das sieht ganz gut aus als
wenn da wirklich so eine nebelwand wäre
wie an seinem kalten wintermorgen oder
so also das finde ich bei diesem shader
echt viel viel besser gelöst als bei dem
sonicwall teenager ich weiß nicht was
besteht aber also da sieht man sieht man
das wirklich wenn man da auf diese auf
diese großen pflanzen da schaut auf das
hohe gras sieht echt aus wie so eine
nebelwand und was ich auch cool finden
an dem schneider ist wenn ich am set
20.000 22.000 mache seht ihr die fackel
macht immens cooles legt erstmals hier
einerseits der mond extrem cool
dargestellt also der hat wirklich solche
wir wenn ihr das hier so seht der
scheint da wirklich wirklich wie sonne
sonne einfach mit seinen mit seinen
streifen darunter über die wolken hinweg
und so das sieht echt cool aus und vor
allem wenn ich eine fackel hinsetze
macht die halt ich find's einfach cooler
vornehmlich ich kann es nicht wirklich
beschreiben von dem licht jetzt her aber
ich finde es einfach schöner mit dem
licht und vor allem auch wenn ihr seht
ich habe eine fackel in der hand und
haben dementsprechend hier einfach um
laufen mit einer fackel und habe damit
quasi meine eigenen lichtquelle wenn ich
die fackel wegpacken quasi kein licht
ich denke ihr versteht was ich damit
sagen möchte und da bin ich jetzt
unsicher ob wir das sehen können bei
einem video werde ich das ja noch nicht
so wirklich sehen konnte
da weiß ich auch gar nicht wie ich mich
gerade hinstellen soll damit ihr das
seht und zwar erscheinen manchmal auf
diesem shader ich versuche mal eben
toggle down voll zu machen damit ihr mal
den regen seht dann mache ich auch mal
wieder times at 10.000 beispielsweise
dann seht ihr wenn es regnet ich habe
nämlich die partikel ausgestellt aber
die da da da sieht man es glaube ich ein
bisschen und zwar wenn ihr mich ich
finds grad nicht also ich sehe es aber
ich weiß dass man bei youtube wieder
nicht sieht und zwar habe ich teilweise
so kleine blaue pünktchen auf meinem so
kleine tropfen auf meinem auf dem
interface hier quasi das sieht dann mega
cool aus wirklich als wenn der regen auf
mich drauf plätschern würde ihr könnt
jetzt auch noch mal bei nebel sehen
beziehungsweise beim regenfall mit
diesem shader sieht einfach mega cool
aus einerseits die fackel macht mir hier
so ein bisschen licht und wenn ich da
hinten hinschaut sieht wirklich so aus
als wenn es da wirklich regnen würde da
liegt so wasser auf dem boden da ist
nebel und so richtig richtig cool
dargestellt das hühnchen läuft hier
gerade auf mich zu macht ein bisschen
terror oder so aber gerade deswegen ich
denke man kann schon sehen wir nicht
einfach mal hinschauen da sieht man
wirklich da ist nass da ist nebel drauf
und ich denke jetzt schon erscheinen
auch teilweise diese blauen pünktchen
dann links wenn jetzt mal links im
bildschirm schaut da kommen immer mal so
ein paar kleine pünktchen auf als
wirklich nebel runterkommen eben runter
komme niemand wasser also regen runter
kommt nicht nebel luca da und ich finde
wenn ich hier einfach so lange laufe das
sieht man schon das sieht einfach mega
cool aus man fühlt sich wirklich so als
wird gerade regnen als wert kalt und
nicht so schön warm und so deswegen ist
das einfach mein platz nummer eins ich
glaube ich hab's euch jetzt lange noch
erklärt warum das mein platz nummer eins
ist ich hoffe dass ihr denen
wieso sage ich den ich meinte das video
ich hoffe dass euch das video gefallen
hat ihr findet die download-links in der
beschreibung und ich würde mich darüber
freuen wenn ihr mir doch mal eure
beschreibung von eurem pop schildern in
die beschreibung wetzlarer nehme in die
kommentare eure reihenfolge der shader
schreiben würdet und eventuell kennt ihr
auch noch bessere shader die ich noch
gar nicht kenne wohl sagt hey wenn ihr
der kula shaker gefällt kann ja auch der
und er gefallen dann bin ich mit dem
dann wahrscheinlich jetzt vielleicht
sogar mehr zufrieden aber hier das ist
wirklich der grund das ist einfach warum
das mein platz eins das ist einfach
wunderschön das wird alles so niedlich
dargestellt und so hier kann man das
schon sehen das wird gerade ein bisschen
nacht und es regnet und da sieht man
wirklich da will man eigentlich gar
nicht hingehen weil das so richtig krass
nämlich da vorne aus sie freunde ich
will gar nicht mehr um heißen brei
herumreden ich hoffe euch hat das video
gefallen
und dann möchte ich euch einfach noch
mal sagen schön dass ihr euch das video
angeschaut habt jetzt vorbei